Hey everyone and welcome back to the
channel. You may notice the change of
scenery in my background here. I'm
actually out of the country at the
moment uh in Amsterdam and I'm totally
here for work and definitely not here to
just go to teen times. But uh yeah,
let's go ahead and do some systems
design. Uh always got to make time for
the channel. So now that we're at it,
let's go ahead and talk about the top K
or the leaderboard problem. Okay, so
today, like I mentioned, we're going to
be doing the top K problem. This is a
problem I've done before on my channel
and I'm not going to deviate the
solution too much, but I would like to
add some color to it where I was missing
it before. So, let's see if we can
improve this video a little bit. So, the
top K problem is a pretty simple
concept. It's something that applies in
a lot of different applications.
However, it's just slightly different
variations of one another. So, here's
the general gist of it. One example
would be finding the top K search terms
on Google over any specific period of
time. The top viewed YouTube videos, the
top songs on Spotify this week. Notice
that we can supply some sort of um kind
of time condition to say what is the top
K over that period of time. And of
course a very challenging problem
indeed. The number of girls who DM
Jordan. The reason it's challenging is
because there are so many of them.
They're so various you probably couldn't
handle it on just one server. Cool. So
like I mentioned very challenging. Okay.
So let's go into some actual specifics
for the problem requirements. Basically
the gist is we're going to be having
lots of incoming events. So in the
examples that I gave, you know, number
of YouTube video views, uh, number of
Spotify listens, number of Google search
terms, those are very common
occurrences. They're not easy to
aggregate, count, and ultimately figure
out what the top K are. So again, this
is going to be a tough problem. If it
was something that happened a lot less
frequently that we could easily count on
a single server and then just return it
back to the user, this problem wouldn't
be all that interesting. Cool. So again,
we're going to do the K most popular
events. Uh, we want to be able to
perform this search over an arbitrary
time range, right? So I could say last
week. I could say you know from 125902
to 125937.
Uh so really any arbitrarily small or
large time range and also uh considering
the fact that there may be billions of
events per day and also for any k value
less than a thousand the bigger that k
value gets the harder it is to compute
these things uh it may not be feasible
uh you know in any reasonable amount of
time. Cool. So note that I'm skipping
the capacity estimates slide here. The
reason being that this problem isn't
really something that is, you know,
specific to a given situation. And so,
as a result, it would be hard for me to
get exact capacity estimates. That being
said, later in the problem, I'll touch
upon a couple of examples there and, you
know, how it's going to actually impact
us when thinking about the answer to
this problem. Cool. So, the overall
approach that we're going to be looking
to take for a problem like this is as
follows. Everything that a user is
doing, we want to make it as fast as
possible. So, that's going to include
actually publishing those events. Right?
If I am going to uh insert a new search
query in Google, I don't want it to take
a while by virtue of having to send my
search term over to the top K service.
And additionally, we also want
leaderboard reads to be fast too. The
next thing is that basically we want to
ensure that getting our results from the
leaderboard are fast. Um and as a result
of that, uh it's possible that we may
actually have to approximate our answer.
So approximations are going to allow us
to have fast reads. Uh, that being said,
they're not going to allow us to have as
precise results, and getting precise
results is going to cause us to have
slower reads. So, there's definitely
going to be a trade-off there. Cool. So,
the first thing that we're going to talk
about is actually going to be the
precise solution to this problem. No
approximation, just how would we
actually get the top K count for any
arbitrary given period of time? Uh,
given that we have all of these incoming
events and there are a ton of them.
Cool. So, the first thing to note is
this. If we want to support any time
range, it means that we actually have to
record and store every single event and
its incoming time stamp. The reason
being that if we were to aggregate them
somehow, we don't actually know whether
each incoming event was within the time
range that we care about or not. So,
it's important that we actually go ahead
and make that distinction. And if we
have this much data, we're probably
going to have to store it in either S3
or Hadoop and then eventually run a
batch job over it. So the first question
is well if we have to put all of these
events in this kind of blob store or
this distributed file system how are
they actually going to get there? So
this is the design that I'm going to
propose. First thing is we have some
sort of server which we'll call the
event publisher. In reality there are
probably going to be many event
publisher servers because there are a
lot of events and we're going to have to
horizontally scale these out. The next
thing that we're going to do is go ahead
and throw those into Kafka. Ideally what
we want to be doing is partitioning them
on an event ID. So for example, if we're
talking about uh you know listens to a
Spotify song, the event ID would be the
song ID. If it's views on a YouTube
video, the event ID would be the video
ID. If it is a number of basically
Google searches for a given search term,
it would be the name of the search term
or something like that. And the reason
we want to do that is so that we can
then go ahead and aggregate them in a
stream processing framework. Here we go.
Peak Jordan back at it. Such as Spark
streaming. And the things that we're
going to do in Spark streaming are going
to be that we're going to aggregate
these like I said over a given windowed
interval. Maybe every hour we'll go
ahead and export them to HDFS. But the
idea is we want to take all of these
individual events which themselves are
not files and basically convert them
into files ideally paret files. The
reason why I say parket is twofold. One,
they're column oriented. So it's really
easy to just read a given column at a
time. We should get some nice
compression on that timestamp column
that we're definitely going to have. And
additionally, the other nice thing with
parquet is that we do have some useful
metadata like row count. So in an ideal
world, um ideally we would only have one
event type per park file because then
the row count would perfectly tell us,
you know, the actual size of that file
and how many um times we saw that event
within a given time range. In reality, I
would imagine those are probably going
to create too many small paret files and
we'll probably have to combine them
together, which is not a huge deal. Um,
but yeah, I mean, generally speaking,
the whole point of Spark streaming here
is we want to make sure that every
single event uh of the same type is
going to the same Spark streaming node
so that we can eventually go ahead and
export it over here to HDFS and throw
our parquet in there. So, that's going
to be step one. In reality though, the
step one of getting our precise answer
is going to be what I'm going to call
the counting phase, which is saying,
okay, well, I've supplied some time
range, maybe let's say last Monday to
this Monday. And what we're going to
have to do now is actually figure out
how many times we saw each event during
that range. So this is not exactly an
easy process or I should say maybe it's
an easy process algorithmically
speaking, but it's not an easy process
because there are tons of these events
and we have to now aggregate all of
their counts. So what does that actually
look like if we were to do some sort of
batch job to figure it out? Well, for
starters, basically every single thing
that we're going to do here is uh just
each Hadoop node is going to check how
many events it has of each type. It's
going to locally sum them up, figure out
its local counts, and then we're going
to have to go ahead and shuffle that
data in order to aggregate the counts of
every single event in that time range.
So, what does this really look like in
reality? Let's say we've got uh on one
Hadoop node, we figure out that okay,
for the search term Jordan, today we've
had a count of 20. For Megan Fox, today
we've had a count of 10. And then
another Hadoop node, which maybe is
storing all our data from yesterday,
says, oh, Jordan had a count yesterday
of 10. Megan Fox had a count yesterday
of five. Now, using basically a hashing
of all those keys, we're going to
shuffle around that data and then sum it
up in total. So, I can see that over the
last two days, which is the date range I
care about, Jordan was searched for 30
times, Megan Fox was searched for 15
times. So, basically, the general idea
here is in this phase of things,
ideally, it would be great if we could
ensure that for every single event ID,
we could have all of those keys already
on the same node. In practice, that's
probably going to be pretty hard uh just
because of, you know, the fact that
we're aggregating over multiple
different dates. And so when we actually
go ahead and do our shuffling, now all
of a sudden we have the counts of every
single event in the time range that we
care about. Cool. So the one uh side
point that I wanted to make on this
slide is perhaps it's possible that we
could do some sort of caching, right? To
actually speed this process up a little
bit where maybe let's say I want the
last 8 days of data. Last 8 days. And
maybe what we could do is if we know
that this is kind of going to be a
frequent process, perhaps I could, you
know, always cache the counts for the
last seven days or, you know, maybe one
week of data. And so I could get that
and then, you know, just find the count
for the one day before that and then sum
that up. That would maybe speed up our
reads a little bit. I think in process
in uh, you know, in in actuality, this
might be a little bit difficult to
actually build because then it just
becomes a matter of, you know, figuring
out all the time range logic. you have
to actually, you know, basically
pre-shuffle all of your uh data together
first to, you know, go ahead and check
if there's any uh sort of cached bigger
range that we can use in order to speed
up our process. So, in reality, I think
this is maybe a little bit less
feasible, but it would be interesting to
see if someone could work that out. Um,
cool. So, let's go ahead and move on.
So, step two, after we have all of the
counts of every single event in the
range that we care about, step two is
going to be to get the top K counts on
every single node. Cool. So again,
that's just going to be a local count.
However, the one thing to note here is
rather than just sort that list by count
per key, we can actually do this a
little bit more efficiently by use of a
min heap. So let's imagine that, you
know, we have K is equal to three. So we
want to find the top three uh counts on
every single node. And let's imagine,
you know, this is the data over here on
the left. Basically, we would start with
our min heap of these three over here,
right? So Jordan, tech, lead, and
Donald. And as you can see, the minimum
element is going to be Donald with a
count of 10. So when Putin comes in with
a count of 20, we can see that Putin is
actually going to be bigger than 10. And
now our min heap is going to look like
this. 100 30 and 20.
And then all of a sudden, oh, we look at
Zuckerberg, we say, "Oh shoot, you know
what? Now Zuckerberg is bigger than
that." So we go to 100, 50, and 30. And
then all of a sudden Elon comes in and
our last heap looks like uh 100 80 and
50.
So why would we want to actually use a
min heap here as opposed to just sorting
the list and then going ahead and taking
the top k entries of that sorted list?
Well, it's actually more efficient to
use a min heap. Reason being that our
time complexity is now going to be
relative to the size of K as opposed to
relative to the size of the entire
sorted list. So because we're doing this
min heap n different times where n is
actually the counts of keys that we have
on this given node, our time complexity
is going to be n log k where log k is
the amount it takes to basically pop our
current uh min element and then add in a
new one as opposed to n log n which is
you know the time complexity of sorting
a list. Cool. Now that we have basically
the sorted top k on every single one of
our htfs nodes, we have to go ahead and
aggregate those. So what does that look
like? Well, this is just going to be the
same as that leak code problem that I'm
sure we're all intimately familiar with,
which is called, I believe, merge and
sorted lists. So, the gist is here that
you basically create yet another heap
with a pointer to every single one of
the sorted lists. And all of the
pointers are first going to start out at
the first element of all of the sorted
lists. And then as we pick an element of
one of the sorted list to put into our
aggregate list, we move forward the
pointer on that sorted list. So, uh,
just to quickly demonstrate what that
looks like here, um, so that everyone
remembers what I'm talking about. Let's
say we're doing a k equals 3, right? And
these are our three sorted lists over
here. 1391, 12, 112, and 1064.
Basically, the way that we're going to
start is we're going to have a pointer
to each list, right? So, the pointer
over here is to list three. The pointer
over here is to list two. Pointer over
here is to list one. Now, because 13 is
the biggest element, we're basically
going to pop 13, put it into our
resulting list over here on the right,
and then now the pointer is going to
point to 9. So, as you can see, we now
have 12, 10, and 9 because 12 is the
biggest element. So, we're going to pop
12 yet again. Now, we go over here, and
now all of a sudden, our heap is going
to look like 11, 10, and 9 because our
pointer is here, our pointer is here,
and our pointer is there. And so,
eventually 11 is still going to be the
biggest element. And now we have 13 12
11. So that is a quick summary of how
you would go ahead and merge sorted
lists a little bit more efficiently. But
again, not too important. Mostly
implementation details. Cool. So the
next thing is that this is going to be
pretty slow. Why? Because basically on
command we have to go ahead and count up
the actual counts of every single event
that occurred uh whenever we want to go
ahead and find the top K for an exact
range. And that's going to be pretty
rough. So the question is what can we
actually do to speed things up? And as
far as the exact solution goes, probably
not that much, unfortunately. But if
we're willing to be a little bit off on
our counts, well then we can actually
start to speed things up quite a bit. So
the first thing to note is that this is
all going to depend on the granularity
of time ranges that we allow, right? So
if I say, oh, you know, maybe instead of
providing any time range to me, you can
only provide time ranges that, you know,
start at a clean hour and end at a clean
hour, right? So that would be the hour
granularity. And so the idea there would
then be, well, if we're only allowing
queries that are multiples of 1 hour
interval, starting and ending at a new
hour, well, all of a sudden, we can
actually just cache the top K for every
single hour and combine them. This is
sort of like one of the stream
processing approaches that we've taken
plenty of times in the past, uh, called
the hopping window, where you aggregate
a bunch of mini windows into a much
bigger window. Cool. So the point here
is that let's say we want the top k for
the last two hours of data. What we
could actually do is sum up all of the
the top ks from uh the last two hours
and then get the top k of those. So for
example, you know, let's say I'm doing
uh k equals 2. So my last hour is, you
know, Jordan
30, Megan Fox
uh 15. And then we also have Jordan.
Here's my my most recent hour. Jordan 40
and then Donald Trump is a 10. So in the
top K over here would actually be uh
Jordan
70 and Megan Fox 15.
Now you should be saying to yourself,
well Jordan, have you considered the
fact that that's not actually right?
Because what if there were events that
were outside of those two top K lists
that you know in aggregate when combined
are actually bigger than both Megan Fox
and Donald Trump. And you'd be correct.
That's why this is an approximate
solution. So again, if there are
elements that are outside of each
window, uh but they manage to ultimately
have bigger counts, we're not going to
end up considering those. And that's why
this isn't a perfect solution. But
again, it's going to be a lot faster
because now rather than having to figure
out the counts of every single event um
you know during any given time interval,
we can actually use the previous top K
cache results for all of the many
intervals that we care about and combine
them into one.
Cool. So the question now becomes, well,
when we want to do this whole windowed
top K solution, how do we calculate it?
Well, for starters, like I mentioned,
um, basically the way that we're
building up this windowed top K solution
is by using exact top K solutions from
every hour interval. And so, if we're
going to do that, well, we can just do
what we described before. We can use
batch processing and every hour we can
run a job that actually calculates the
top K for that hour. And then we can put
it somewhere like a time series
database. Or another option is if we
want those results a little bit faster,
right? Because batch processing is going
to take a little bit to get started and
trigger. What we could actually
potentially do is use stream processing.
So, here's how I would go ahead and do
this. And again, incoming Flink just
warning you before you get triggered.
Cool. So, we're going to uh populate
these results hopefully a little bit
more quickly into our time series
database. And here's how we can do it.
So, like I mentioned, we've got Kafka.
Kafka is going to hold all of the
events. Kafka is going to be sharded on
event ID.
Cool. Then those are all going to go
into Spark streaming. The reason I keep
saying Spark streaming here as opposed
to Flink is because, you know, why not
many batch these events, it's just less
things to send over the network to our
Spark streaming consumer. Cool. Again,
what's now going to happen on both of
these is not only are we going to create
the Paret files here to put into HDFS,
but we can also actually aggregate the
count of each local event. And that's
effectively just going to be a hash
table from event ID to the count. So
simple enough, right there. Then what
we're going to do is let's say every
hour or whatever the granularity is that
we want to publish these top K results,
we can go ahead and compute our local
top K. So you know whatever it is that
we have on this node, let's find the top
K of those. Cool. So we're going to do
that. Export them over here into our
second Kafka Q, which I'll call the
local top K accounts Q. And then from
there, we can actually go ahead and use
a second stream consumer, in this case
again, Flink, to actually merge all of
those sorted lists. So I'll take the
local top K from this consumer and from
our bottom consumer. We'll merge them
together and then we'll throw them in
the time series database. So that's
actually pretty easy, right? Uh the one
thing to note is that well it becomes a
question of how does this guy actually
know when he's received all of the local
top Ks? It's not that simple, right?
Because we actually have to now know how
many Spark streaming consumers that we
have because all of them are going to
publish a local top K event. Well, at
least in this case, if I were doing
this, I would probably have my Flink
node over here listening to Zookeeper.
The reason being that Zookeeper is going
to have the information of how many
Spark streaming consumers there are each
listening to a Kafka Q. We can basically
go ahead and register with Zookeeper
when we're a Spark streaming consumer
that's actually starting up. And so, as
long as we go ahead and register a watch
on that, you know, we can keep track of
and say, oh, there are two consumers.
So when I receive two top K lists,
you know, for hour 8 o'clock,
once I get both and once I merge them,
then I can go over to the time series
database and say, "Hey, here's your top
K for the 8:00 hour." Cool. Hopefully
that makes a decent amount of sense. So
now we know how we're actually going to
write all of these mini top K intervals,
but how are we actually going to go
ahead and read them? So let's say I
wanted to do the following. I'm a client
over here and I want to see the top 10
of all my events for the last 3 hours.
Maybe it's uh top 10 most listened to
Spotify songs in the last 3 hours. So,
the first thing that we're going to do
is we're going to hit our leaderboard
service and say, "Hey, we want to know
this." And the leaderboard service is
going to say, "Oh, shoot. You know what?
I have to go ahead and go to the time
series database and figure out the
counts for all three of those hours."
So, note that uh I'm representing this
as three time series database
partitions. In reality, there's a good
chance they're probably on the same
node, which would make things faster
because then we don't have to do so many
network calls. But keep in mind that in
a time series database, all of the data
is effectively partitioned by the actual
time interval and the source. And so if
these guys have time intervals uh or
different time intervals, technically,
we may be going to a different uh chunk
table in the time series database, which
is almost represented as a partition. So
whatever we're going to the hour ago
chunk table, the 2hour ago chunk table,
the three-hour ago chunk tables. We're
getting those back and then on the
leaderboard server right here, the first
thing that we're going to do is use a
hashmap to aggregate the total counts,
right? We loop through all of these
results and sum up the the counts per
event. Then we use a min heap to
basically say, all right, you know,
maybe we have 20 unique events here and
we want to get the top 10. Let's go
ahead and use our min heap to get the
top 10 of them. And then finally, we're
just going to go ahead and return that
to the user. So hopefully that makes
sense as to how we would read those top
k uh in the approximation scenario.
Cool. Now, one thing to note about what
I just described before is that even
though stream processing should be
relatively quick in terms of publishing
those results to the time series
database, what if we actually wanted to
do it faster? Well, the main thing is
that we have a bottleneck, right?
Because at the end of the day, all of
our Spark streaming consumers which are
aggregating their local counts are going
to have to coordinate with one another
and combine their local counts in order
to first publish to the time series
database. So the question is how could
we avoid this? Well, the answer is the
only way to actually avoid this is by
basically um aggregating all the counts
on a single node and then that single
node can itself publish directly to the
time series database. Otherwise, we're
always going to have to have this second
layer, this second coordination phase
where we aggregate all of the counts
across each Spark streaming node. So,
the first question should be, well, is
this actually possible? Because at the
end of the day, if we have billions of
unique events and we have to count them
all, it might actually take too much
storage to be held on a single node in
memory, right? Maybe we can put 256 GB
of RAM on a single node. It may not
actually be enough. So we're actually
going to introduce here is a second way
of approximating the count that actually
uses only a fixed size of memory. So
we're going to use an algorithm called
count min sketch which I have talked
about on this channel before basically
for this very problem. So let's go ahead
and talk about it again. So the main
idea of count min sketch is that we're
going to have some fixed size buffer
right where the buffer is almost like a
2D matrix and that's what we're looking
at right here. So basically in order to
generate this buffer to make it useful,
we're going to define a few different
hash functions. Let's say in this case
we're going to define three of them. H1,
H2, H3. And each of them can put your
given result into five different
buckets, which I've got over here.
Now, of course, I would imagine there
would be more than three hash functions
and more more than five different
buckets in reality, but this is just for
demonstration sake. Cool. So let's say
some event A comes in and when we get H1
of A or we take the hash H1 of A, it's
going to return bucket one. So that puts
us over there. When we do H2 of A, it's
going to return bucket four. I'm one
indexing these buckets for you coders.
So that's why A is over here. When we do
H3 of A, it's going to put us in bucket
two. Hence why we see an A over here. So
then let's go ahead and process B. If we
do the same thing, B goes here for H1. B
goes here for H2. And then B goes here
for H3. And then yet again, we're going
to process A one more time. So again,
that's why we see the second A here, the
second A here, the second A here. Great.
So now to actually approximate the count
of each element, all we're going to do
is basically say, all right, well, I
know that my three buckets for A are 1,
4, and two. So let's see. In this bucket
here, I see two elements. In this bucket
here, I see three elements. And in this
bucket here, I see two elements. And so
our count that we're actually going to
use for A is the minimum of those, which
is going to be two. We're going to do
the same thing for B. In this bucket
here, I see one element. In this bucket
here, I see three elements. And in this
bucket here, I see one element. The
minimum of those being one. So, we're
actually going to use this approximation
to approximate that our count of A is
two and B is one. And in this case,
that's actually going to be correct.
Obviously, as you have more elements
coming in, it is going to skew further
and further from the truth. Uh, but
there are some mathematical bounds in
terms of how big you want to make your
sketch in order to be relatively
accurate. Cool. So, let's continue
talking about this guy a little bit
because this is where, in my opinion, it
gets a little bit more interesting. So,
imagine we actually have enough memory
to make a decent approximation on the
counts of every single node or or not
every single node, but uh every single
event. So, we're able to process those
counts decently well, but can we
actually handle the load decently well?
Because if you think about it, forget
how much storage we need. We also need
to actually be able to handle incoming
events fast enough that we can, you
know, reasonably post them to a time
series database within not that much
time. And so, if you actually look at
objective results, you know, if you're
Google, you're publishing around 100,000
search terms per second. And to some
extent, this could be handled, right?
We're going to stick all of this in our
Kafka queue. And it turns out that Kafka
can process around a million writes per
second. So Kafka will actually be able
to handle this or at least it should be
able to. The question is, can our
countman sketch server handle it? So for
us to do that, we want to make this
thing as fast as humanly possible and be
processing writes as quickly as humanly
possible. So in order to best do that,
we want to avoid contention. And when I
say contention, what I really mean is
two threads on our countman sketch
server grabbing the same lock and
slowing each other down because one has
to wait on another to grab that lock. So
the idea here is, you know, we have a
bunch of different Kafka partitions.
We're subscribing to all of them on a
different thread. Uh meaning that
basically each thread is pulling from
one Kafka partition one at a time and
then also writing into that centralized
countman sketch. So basically the idea
is you know in order to avoid locking on
the sketch itself every single hour we
can basically just take our countman
sketch send it to another thread and say
hey you go do the aggregation here and
then send it to the time series database
and then additionally because of the
fact that we now have multiple different
threads writing events into our same
countman sketch. Note that uh these are
all integers and we don't want to lose
any updates there. we actually have to
use atomic integers which it does
involve locking under the hood in order
to you know properly aggregate counts
and so if there's a lot of contention
within our countman sketch right if a
lot of things are going to the same
bucket at the same time we could in
theory deal with locking problems cool
so is there anything that we could
actually potentially do to avoid that oh
also quick interruption uh not locking
related again but um if you guys are
aware of what kernel bypass is basically
a way of reading data over the network
not having to basically first copy it
into the Linux kernel and then copy it
into memory or or there's not an extra
step of dealing with the Linux kernel.
Uh you would basically copy it straight
from your network card potentially into
memory. And so that uh could potentially
speed things up as well, but uh I think
that's a little bit too niche for the
sake of the systems assigned interview.
Cool. So let's continue talking about
countman sketch. So the main thing here,
right, is that we want to avoid
contention. We've got multiple different
threads reading from multiple different
Kafka partitions and they can interrupt
one another if they're all hitting the
same buckets of our sketch. Cool. So the
nice thing that we could actually
potentially do here is instead we could
actually have each thread keep its own
countman sketch. So this is an
interesting thought in the sense that
now all of a sudden you're basically
just writing one at a time from the
Kafka Q as fast as you can handle them
into your own countman sketch and then
eventually you know every hour all
different threads are going to send all
of their countman sketches to one other
thread which is going to merge them
together aggregate them and then export
them to the time series database. So
yes, technically there now is that kind
of merging step which we wanted to
avoid, but at the same time, we don't
actually have to send that data over the
network, which is pretty important and
could potentially speed things up a bit.
Cool. So the first thing to note is that
that now means that each thread is going
to have to have a smaller sketch for
itself, right? Because we're limited by
how much memory we have on the machine.
If we have four different threads, now
our sketch per thread has to be 1/4 of
the size. And uh I did note that this
isn't necessarily a huge deal because at
the end of the day considering that each
thread is pulling from a partitioned
Kafka Q, I would think that if we're
partitioning well, there would probably
be around a quarter of the number of
event IDs per Kafka. And so we shouldn't
have as many conflicts in each countman
sketch. Cool. And the next thing is that
we're going to have to actually go ahead
and merge every single thread's top K
and the exporter thread like I
mentioned, which is going to add
additional latency. but at the end of
the day is probably not too huge of a
deal. Great.
So the last aspect of this that I want
to talk about is going to be fault
tolerance. So because of the fact that
we're basically just having ourselves a
server here which is standing up in
memory reading from a bunch of Kafka
cues and it's not really checkpointing
its state or anything like that or using
any tactic that Flink or Spark streaming
might use. We want to be sure that if
this thing goes down we're not
completely screwed. So the way that we
can actually do that is by using
something called state machine
replication which we see in a few
different systems design patterns and
are especially relevant for things like
stream consumption. So the idea here is
rather than you know checkpointing our
state occasionally to S3 which can take
a while. What we can do instead is just
set up a second countman sketch server
reading from all the same exact Kafka
cues and also we could even have it
publishing to the time series database
as well. We could literally just call
out a second source like CMS2 or
something and read from there if CMS1 is
down or not publishing new data. So
yeah, the general idea of state machine
replication is, you know, if your
algorithm is deterministic and you're
reading from the exact same place, you
should end up having the same exact
state on your CMS2 server.
All right, so let's go ahead and bring
this thing all together. We've got our
top K problem diagram going. So let's go
ahead and talk about it. The first
aspect of this thing is going to
literally just be publishing events. If
I listen to a song on Spotify, we have
to go ahead and publish that somewhere.
So really the only publishing that we're
going to do is first just putting it
into Kafka because we want to make this
write as quick as possible. Kafka can
fortunately process a lot of writes very
quickly. So this shouldn't make things
too slow for the user. So once that's in
Kafka, basically our right path is done.
Now everything else is on the
aggregation path. So those writes from
our Kafka event cues which are sharded
on our event ID can basically go to a
few different places. The first place
that they can go to is our countman
sketch server. So like I mentioned due
to state machine replication we have
both a primary and a secondary and that
is going to be aggregating approximate
counts of all the events every single
hour and then exporting them over here
to our time series database which also
does have a replica just for fall
tolerance. Cool. The next thing to note
is that besides all of the countman
sketch stuff, we can also go ahead and
fetch all of these Kafka events on
partition spark streaming nodes. So
these are also just going to be rather
than reading from all of the Kafka
partitions, we have one spark streaming
consumer per partition. So those are
going to do two things. The first thing
is that they're going to be uh basically
caching all of the counts of every
single event that's come in for the last
hour. And every single hour we're going
to compute our local top K there. Go
ahead and export that into Kafka. And
then from Kafka, we have a Flink
instance listening to all of the local
top Ks as well as Zookeeper. Oh my gosh,
I keep just erasing things. I don't know
why it's doing this to me. So, we're
going to be listening to both Zookeeper
and all of our local top Ks from all of
our Spark streaming nodes. Uh the reason
being that we need Zookeeper to
basically tell us how many Spark
streaming nodes there are. We go ahead
and aggregate those and then eventually
when we're done we can publish that to
the time series database. In theory the
the local top ks from the spark
streaming nodes should be more accurate
than the ones coming from the countman
sketch because we can actually store the
counts of every single event rather than
using approximation algorithm to get
them. Again though when you know when we
want to aggregate multiple of these
windows via the leaderboard service
right so this is where we say oh I want
the last 3 hours of data
but you know we only have the top k
in 1 hour intervals
that's still technically an
approximation too cool so hopefully that
all makes sense the last aspect of this
is actually going to be the exact
solution right saying you know if I have
um if I have a weird time range or just
you know I want to know the exact
answer. Maybe I'm a business analyst and
it's very important to me to get the
perfect results. What we're going to
have to do is ultimately read everything
from HTFS. So the way that we would do
that is by first exporting parquet files
there every hour with the counts of
every single event and actually their
exact timestamps as well. We don't want
to do any aggregation here to give us
the maximum flexibility uh per time
range. And then from there what's going
to happen is we would run a spark job as
we described originally. you know, our
leaderboard service can go ahead and
trigger this thing and then once we run
that spark job, return the results of
the top K back to the leaderboard
service and back to our user. Okay,
guys. Well, I hope this makes a little
bit more sense. Uh, the one part of this
problem that I did want to focus on a
little bit was actually how we wanted to
deal with concurrency on the countman
sketch servers since I don't really
think I touched upon that enough. And
the truth is, if you're trying to handle
every single event that is incoming from
a major application like Google,
YouTube, or Spotify on one single
server, you're really going to have to
make that thing super fast. So, uh,
hopefully it makes a little bit of sense
how we can actually go ahead and avoid
having to use locks and dealing with
contention. And if it does, then maybe
this video is all right. Anyways, guys,
have a great rest of your week. I'm
going to attempt to do the same out here
and I will see you in the next